- [Interviewer] All right,
Gwen, Gwen welcome back.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] So, last time
we spoke, you were fresh,
you're a brand new porn actress.
- [Gwen] Yes, I was.
I had done maybe two
scenes last time we spoke.
- [Interviewer] Just like a
few weeks into the business.
So now, you're a seasoned veteran.
- Yes, I am a year and three weeks.
- [Interviewer] Has it been a year?
- Hm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Interviewer] Wow.
So how have things changed?
- Oh, well, I'm definitely more...
I think I grew into
myself over the year a lot
way quicker than I would've
if I was not in porn.
And I'm just a much more
confident, more open person now.
- [Interviewer] How old are you again?
- I'm 22.
- You're 22.
- Hm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Interviewer] And this
career is not for everyone.
- No.
- Certainly.
But, you told me last time I think
that you were kind of very
curious and this very sexual
and this kind of works for you.
- Yeah, I'm a learner.
I love to learn new things
and I love to try new things.
I cannot take people's word for anything.
I have to go and find it out for myself.
So that in combination
with being a pretty open
and experimental person sexually,
porn seemed like the perfect idea.
And to me, it really was.
I really found something I
enjoy and it's not for everyone
but I think if you have a tough skin
and you enjoy having sex,
you should try it definitely.
- [Interviewer] And so,
do you have friends here?
You've made friends?
- I have, I've made friends.
- [Interviewer] And the people you meet
that are outside the
business, do you tell them or?
- I do, I tell people that I do porn.
I usually don't say, "I do porn."
Whenever people ask what I do,
I tell them I do adult modeling
and they're like, "Oh, okay.
So you do porn."
And I'm like, "Yeah."
And I'm lucky enough that the
people I've met don't mind.
- [Interviewer] And does
your family know about it?
- Yeah, my family knows about it.
- [Interviewer] And
how did they take that?
- They were pretty accepting of it.
Both my parents, my mom
and my dad were like,
"It's not really what we
would want you to be doing,"
but I've always been someone who just does
what I want anyways, no
matter what anyone thinks.
And my parents know that.
So they were supportive of the decision.
They were like, "You're
making your own choices
and we're proud of you for that."
- [Interviewer] That's pretty progressive
for a Kansas family that.
- Yeah, it is pretty
progressive, I guess, for Kansas.
- [Interviewer] And you feel safe,
you're not being exposed
to anything dangerous
or anything like that?
- No, I feel safe.
One thing about porn
is it's very important
that everyone's comfortable.
They make that pretty clear from day one.
You can't, you shouldn't
and you won't do anything
you don't wanna do.
And every time I'm on set,
every time I meet a new
person in the industry
I'm always comfortable,
way more comfortable
than I've been with strangers, really.
So it's a good place to be.
- [Interviewer] What is your experience
with the professionalism
and the other coworkers?
Is everyone respectful
and easy to work with,
or do you get some weird
situations sometimes?
- For the most part,
everyone's very professional.
At least the people I've worked with.
The majority of them have
been people who have been
in the industry for a few years.
So they're experienced
and they know what they
want from the industry.
So they do their best
to be a professional,
respectful and kind person.
If there ever is someone
who's not super-professional
or super-nice, they're usually brand new,
a little bit younger and
they're just they're excited
that they're doing porn,
so they get kind of a cocky attitude.
But that doesn't matter.
At the end of the day,
they're your coworkers
some of them you get along with,
and some of them you don't,
but the majority of the time
you get along with them.
- [Interviewer] So you seem pretty happy.
- I am, I am pretty happy.
Porn quite literally saved my life from...
From where I was to where I
am now, mentally, emotionally,
and even health-wise physically
I'm a much better off person.
And I don't think I could have done that
without the openness that porn gives me.
- [Interviewer] Your personality
might be perfectly suited
to this career,
'cause I think it would
chew up and spit out
a lot of people, right?
- Yeah, you see it happen too.
Even when I first started,
that's one of the things
that my agency told me about,
they're like, "Before you
dive into this be 100% certain
that you can handle certain things."
Your naked body's everywhere online.
People are gonna judge it,
they're gonna talk to you about it.
And you have a scarlet A on your chest
for the rest of your life
like, "Oh, they did porn."
And some people can't handle that.
Some people feel very guilty for it.
And they end up leaving
the industry very early on,
'cause they realize it's
not what they wanted.
And so, I made certain that
that is what I wanted to do
before I went into it.
I researched it for a
long time before doing it.
So yeah, definitely.
It's the right place for me,
but I've seen and know of
people that it's not
the right place for it.
- [Interviewer] Are you making good money?
- I am.
Yeah, and it's good, it's good money.
And sometimes it can be nerve-wracking,
'cause it's not consistent.
You're a model, you don't
have a set schedule.
You work when people hire
you to work, it's random,
but it's you don't have
to work a 9:00 to 5:00
for five days a week to
get a decent paycheck.
- [Interviewer] You're
basically freelance.
So, it comes when it comes and-
- You keep it, you save it.
- [Interviewer] Otherwise,
you're not working.
- Yeah, it's just like most artists is
freelance is how they work.
- [Interviewer] Well,
pretty much everybody
in the working world is
being exploited or used,
whether you work at a
department store or a bank
or anything, you're
doing things for money.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And you're
certainly doing things for money.
- Yes.
- Do you ever feel like
you're being disrespected or exploited
or anything like that?
I mean, especially with your
situation where you're giving
much more than just your time.
- Yeah, you dedicate your
entire being into porn.
That's your body out there
that you're using for your job.
- [Interviewer] I think
there's a little more,
I mean, maybe I'm off base here.
Tell me if I am.
But with what you do, it's
a little more of your soul
is being given then somebody
who works at a grocery store.
- Yeah, you're putting yourself
into all these situations
and you're sharing such an
intimate aspect of yourself
with people that you're just
meeting for the first time
or you're never gonna see them again.
Or if you do see them again,
they've also had sex with 20 other people
within that span of a time.
So it's like,
I don't feel used.
I don't feel like I am being
exploited or disrespected
in any way, because it is
I'm consenting to everything
that's happening, right?
It's the first thing you do
when you walk in the door
is you fill out these forms,
you talk about, "Hey, are
you consenting to this?"
"Yes, I'm consenting to this."
Did anyone make me do this?
No, no one made me do this.
And you talk about your do's and don'ts
and what you like, what you don't like
all that kind of stuff beforehand.
And so, the only way to me
that you could feel
disrespected or exploited
in this industry is if you
personally, secretly deep down
don't like what you're doing.
So the only way to feel disrespected to me
is if you put yourself in a situation,
you didn't know you didn't want to be in,
but you can,
if you don't make your own
informed decision on things.
- [Interviewer] What are
some of the strange things
you're required to do in this?
- [Gwen] One time I had to
get throat fucked repeatedly
until I puked.
And I had to puke into a bowl a dog bowl
that said, "Whore," on it.
And then at the end of it, they
dumped the puke on my head.
And then the dude, pissed it off of me.
- [Interviewer] And how do you feel
driving home from work that day?
- [Gwen] Dirty.
I was like, "That was the
dirtiest shit I've ever done."
- [Interviewer] I mean,
doesn't this impact you
some way subconsciously?
- No.
- No, it would me.
- [Gwen] I mean, I just really wanted
to take a bubble bath afterwards.
I was like, "Okay, that was intense,"
'cause it was an intense scene.
I got slapped around and
yelled at and degraded
and all that kind of stuff.
And then, I got peed on and
I had my puke all over me
and I got pee guy the next day because-
- [Interviewer] I mean,
I don't watch porn,
so I don't know what's
going on in the industry,
but I've heard some stories
like what you just described.
Is it getting more demented
and more extreme like that?
- More extreme.
I think so.
I think, because there's
so much porn out there,
there was so much porn
and there's so many
people that do porn now,
especially with OnlyFans
and all these clip sites
that anybody can just upload porn.
You don't have to have a
DVD or whatever or a VHS.
You can use your phone to do it.
So you have to do weird extreme stuff
to get noticed by anyone.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like porn and things like that,
all kinds of sex work kind of undermines
the moral thread of society?
I mean, there's so many different ways
of looking at this, but then
a lot of people would say
that this is all bad for society.
It's bad for mankind that everyone's-
- I think that I don't
necessarily think it's bad
for mankind.
I can understand that,
the media you consume
has an impact on your life and who you are
and how you act.
But it doesn't have to.
That's where self-control comes in.
Porn is very satirized,
you see it everywhere.
I can't open up my phone
without seeing a naked girl on Twitter
or Instagram or something.
And it's so normal to see
that stuff all the time.
And I think that's changed
the way people view themselves
and relationships with people and stuff,
but it doesn't have to.
You can not look at that
stuff or you can realize that
the things in porn are just fantasy
and these are professionals
acting these scenarios out.
You don't have to take it to your core,
this is what the media wants you to do
or this is what the media
wants you to look like.
Know that's just what
the media is producing
because it can.
So I think it takes a little
bit of personal responsibility
within yourself before
you can blame porn on-
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but
you're being pushed to do
more and more extreme things.
- I am, I am always being pushed
to do more and more extreme
things, but I like it.
That's what I do.
I love BDSM and Kink and Fetish.
- [Interviewer] So maybe again,
you might be perfectly
suited to this career.
- Yeah, I'm suited for the career.
If you're not someone
who likes those things
then you shouldn't do porn,
or you can do porn if you
just did very specific
what you wanna to do.
But yeah, I'm always trying new things
and there's always something else.
You go to set and you're like,
"Wow this was the weirdest,
craziest shit I've ever done."
And then you go to another
set and you're like,
"Oh no, this is the weirdest,
craziest shit I've ever done."
It's always something new.
I don't know, it's cool.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever feel like
you're selling something of yourself
that you question later,
whether it's right?
- Sometimes, you have to...
I don't think I'm selling things
that aren't right to myself.
If there's a role that I don't wanna do
then I won't do it.
I'll be like, "Thanks for the offer,
but no, I'm not comfortable with that."
But there are times where I'm like,
"Oh gosh, this character is totally
not how my personality is like."
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's just acting.
- Yeah, I was just acting.
So I get a little nervous
that people are like,
"Oh, they're gonna think
I'm some sweet innocent bimbo little girl.
And that's totally not who I am.
So sometimes you feel like
people don't see your true self,
but that's about it for selling yourself.
- [Interviewer] That's just acting though.
- Yeah, it's just acting.
- [Interviewer] And your
romantic life, your personal life
is it affected by this?
Or do you have one?
- No, I don't have a romantic life at all.
- [Interviewer] I think a
lot of people in the industry
have told me the same thing where they-
- Yeah, it's just-
- [Interviewer] It's hard-
- It's hard to balance because people
obviously here are like, "Oh, you do porn.
Well, then that means it's okay
if we hook up all the time,
'cause it's just casual for you."
And I'm like, "Actually I care
a lot about my sexual health,
because I do porn and I don't
wanna hook up with people
all the time."
And especially, people that aren't okay
with being tested or
using condoms or anything.
And I think that puts a
little bit of a damper
on my romantic life,
because I'm not willing
to just sleep with anyone.
And then, also no one
wants to date someone
who has to have sex with
other people all the time.
So then, that's also a thing,
but I don't really care about it
'cause you're only young once,
so I might as well make money
doing what I can while I can
and worry about the romantic shit later.
- [Interviewer] You
might be one of the few
that's really cut out
for this line of work.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm cut out for it.
I know a lot of girls
who really, truly aren't cut out for it.
They're passionate about
what they're doing.
And you can tell in the videos
whether someone enjoys it
or whether they're just
doing it for a paycheck.
And I hope people see in my content
that I enjoy what I'm doing.
I'm not pretending to
like what's happening.
I do everything I do,
because I enjoy doing it.
And I think that's one of the things
that's really important
to me with being in porn
is just do what you wanna to do.
Don't do anything you don't wanna do
'cause you don't have to.
- [Interviewer] And what was
the most important lesson
you've learned you think?
You're still young, but
what have you learned
since you've been doing this?
- That, this is gonna sound so cheesy
but it's literally, life
is what you make it.
Your life is how you make your life.
I know not everyone has
the privilege to just go
and make money being hot.
But it wasn't an easy journey,
but one day I woke up and I decided,
"Hey, I wanna be a
model, I wanna do porn."
And I did it.
And I noticed that sometimes
if I am on set and I'm not feeling myself,
I'm not happy, I'm not thinking
I look good or whatever,
like insecurities and all
that, then the scene is bad.
You can see it on my face.
But then if I show up and
I keep a positive attitude,
I feel like I look good I just
get yourself in that mindset,
then I make a good scene.
And doing that over and over again,
it made me realize anything
that I'm doing in my life
is exactly how I make it.
I can make it good or I can make it bad.
And so I just, and I
think porn made me realize
for the first time in my life
that I am my own success
or I am my own misery.
So, I finally figured out
that I can take responsibility
for what I do and how I feel about it.
- [Interviewer] That's great, awesome.
You're becoming a wise
sage, as you do porn.
- Yes, yes, I'm all wise and mentally,
I'm like an 80-year-old man sipping tea
in his little cottage.
- [Interviewer] In your lingerie.
- Yeah, just chilling all sexy,
but I'm like, I got, I do, I don't know,
I just got this older
mentality I feel like
since I started porn.
It just, you learn so much about yourself
in such a small amount of time.
- [Interviewer] You're certainly taking
alternative path to maturity.
- Yeah, Yeah.
I took, instead of slowly
climbing up the ladder,
I just took an escalator.
And I was like, "We're gonna to do it."
If I'm gonna figure my life out
I'm gonna figure it out
now and I'm gonna do it
in the most extreme way possible.
- [Interviewer] Yes you did.
You chose that path.
All right, Gwen.
Well, thank you so much
for coming in again.
- Yeah, thank you for having me again.
- [Interviewer] And I
wish you the best of luck.
- [Gwen] I wish you the best of luck.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- [Gwen] Thank you.